c'est à toi
donc cette en 2006 je disais que le
washington post aux états unis publient
les résultats dans son sondage qui
montre les résultats suivants 96 pardon
94% des personnes qui ont été
questionnés estimait être plus honnête
que la moyenne 80 9% de ces personnes
estimaient posséder davantage de bon
sens que la moyenne est dans la même
série
86 % estimaient être plus intelligent
que la moyenne alors ce même sondage a
été également effectués en milieu
carcéral
le résultat était absolument similaire
par rapport au reste de la population
sentant bien entendu alors voilà au fond
ce que ces chiffres nous montrent c'est
une tendance tendance générale est
marquée chez l'être humain à exagérer
les les caractéristiques
ces caractéristiques lui sont propres
ses traits de caractère souhaitables par
rapport à la moyenne de ses congénères
alors de façon assez intéressante cet
effet disparaît complètement lorsqu'on
demande à ces mêmes personnes
ouvrons de décrire ces mêmes
caractéristiques chez les personnes
tierces et non pas par rapport à
eux-mêmes
au fond on est bien meilleur pour juger
les autres que soi même
voilà donc au fond cette cet effet que
l'on que l'on aime tout à fait
opportunément effet meilleure que la
moyenne est un effet qui fait partie de
la grande famille des illusions
cognitives ses illusions cognitives sont
à l'intelligence ce que les élus
giroptic sont à la vue alors c'est ans
ce sont des désillusions
comment dire plus précisément ce sont
des illusions qui reflète une limitation
de nos processus mentaux qui génère un
certain nombre d'erreurs systématique
dans nos perceptions nos jugements ainsi
que nos prises de décision ça je crois
que c'est cet essentiel là dedans voilà
on non on en compte environ une centaine
de ses illusions cognitives c'est quand
même important dont 10 sont
particulièrement robuste alors tout ça
c'est le résultat du travail de
messieurs amos vers ce qui est daniel
kahneman daniel kahn est mal à
d'ailleurs reçu en 2002 le prix nobel
d'économie pour sa théorie qu'il a
appelé sa théorie des perspectives qui
dit qu' une que la charge émotionnelle
lors d'une situation de perte
admettons vous avez bien perdu 50 euros
est ressentie deux fois plus fortement
que la charge émotionnelle ressenti
lorsque vous avez un gain de valeur
équivalente
ça se reflète en fait part ce petit ce
petit graphique
cette asymétrie entre les charges
émotionnelles pertes et d'un gain
ce sont en fait fontana souffrent aussi
d' explications de phénomènes qui relève
de la finance comportementale par
exemple comme pour prendre un cas des
investisseurs en bourse ont tendance en
fait assez marquée à conserver des
titres qui ont perdu de la valeur alors
que ils ont tendance à en vendre plus
vite ceux qui ont gagné de la valeur
ça c'est un phénomène que l'on n'a
constaté expérimentalement de façon
assez assez fréquentes
voilà alors un jeu
je vais vous présenter quelques-uns de
ses de ses travers cognitif dissonance
cognitive
la première c'est l'ancrage alors
l'ancrage c'est un phénomène qui fait
que lorsque l'on fixe que l'on fixant
une valeur comme point de référence
cette valeur aura pour effet de
d'influencé une action ou une décision
ultérieure
je vous donne un petit exemple on va
prendre des juges ou very j'aime bien
les juges parce qu'ils sont censés être
objectif
elle ne pas être influençable ce qui est
pas tout à fait vrai mais je vais et il
voit là on a pris tout un groupe de
juges et on leur a demandé d'écrire sur
une feuille de papier un numéro
aléatoire en fait entre 0 et 100 chacun
avait son numéro différent
ensuite on leur a demandé de faire un
travail qui leur est tout à fait
familiers
c'est à dire de d'étudier un cas est de
déterminer une dédommagement qui serait
dû à un plaignant dans un cas précis on
a constaté que les juges qui avaient
écrit sur leurs petits papiers un
chiffre dans le bas de la fourchette de
0 à 100 sous-évaluait systématiquement
le dédommagement du aux plaignants
évidemment à l'opposé ceux qui avaient
écrit à un chiffre dans le haut de la
fourchette à surestimer le différentiel
était de l'ordre de 30% ce qui est très
loin d'être négligeable
alors ça c'est cette ce problème au fond
de l'ancrage que l'on retrouve dans dans
pas mal de situations par exemple bon
après dans la certainement tous fait
moi également c'est à dire que dans une
négociation par exemple le premier qui
pose le prix a un avantage parce qu'il a
créé un ancrage on va négocier en fait
autour de ce prix s'il n'est pas
complètement dans les choux bien entendu
mais on va on va travailler autour de ce
prix c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est
important quand on négocie d'être le
premier à poser a pris alors dans
l'immobilier aussi on a vu que ça n'est
certain succès voilà donc ça s'éteint
c'est un fait alors là on voit dans le
cas de la négociation que le nom cragin
lien avec le résultat avec l'objet
discuter mais dans le premier cas des
juges
l'ancrage n'a pas de lien et c'est ça
qui est intéressant parce que au niveau
aussi du marketing à une autre
expérience très intéressante a été fait
sept ans d'imaginer une super marché qui
décide de faire une promotion de 10% sur
des boîtes de soupe
bon alors certains jours un côté de
cette promotion
on va mettre un panneau limité à 12 par
client d'autres jours on va rien m il
n'y aura pas de limites
alors quel va être le résultat est bien
dans les situations où le panneau est
placée avec une limite à nous on fait
deux fois plus de ventes
que dans le cas où il n'y a pas de
limite 1 pourquoi parce qu'on a fixé un
cadre de référence un ancrage un chiffre
est en moyenne les clients qui s'étaient
servis de ces boîtes là ont pris sept
mois tu s'approche d'eux n'était pas au
maximum ils ont pris cette boîte quand
même deux fois plus que dans l'autre
situation
maintenant un autre
notre dissonance cognitive qui a peut
être beaucoup plus d'implication qui est
un peu plus complexe mais je vais
essayer de vous illustrer ça ça
s'appelle en fait la négligence du taux
de base tenant un petit peu barbare mais
la situation est la suivante
imaginez une personne qui va voir son
médecin pour un check-up normal mais le
médecin a pour tâche de dépister
systématiquement une maladie imaginez le
cancer du sein on peut faire un
dépistage systématique dans la
population féminine bien sûr et le
médecin des pistes
grâce à un test un test agnostique qui
est précis à 99%
je viens un peu trop vite qui est précis
à 99% ça veut dire que ce test à 1% de
marge d'erreur alors maintenant le
patient se fait tester le texte revient
il est déclaré malade malheureusement le
texte revient positif les déclarés
malades avec une probabilité de 99%
on conçoit facilement l' angoisse que
cela peut générer dans un cas comme
celui là
maintenant il se renseigne un petit peu
plus avant sur sur cette maladie
il découvre que le taux de prévalence
dans la population de cette maladie et
de une personne sur mille à la france ça
fait un peu moins de 70 milles personnes
potentiellement touchées par cette
maladie pendant la question est la
suivante est ce que cette nouvelle
information
sachant que le patient est malade avec
une probabilité de 99%
est ce que cette nouvelle information
est susceptible de
ils ont de leurs assurés ou n'a pas d'
influence ou encore est susceptible
d'augmenter son angoisse cette question
a été posée très largement à des
collèges de médecins rappellent la
faculté de médecine de harvard et si
vous êtes comme la majorité des gens au
mieux cette nouvelle information n'a
aucune espèce d'influencé le premier
test et au pire augmente légèrement
votre angoisse parce que vous savez
qu'un à d'autres qui qui sont malades ça
j'ai pu le tester sur sur des personnes
devant la réalité est complètement
opposé
la réalité c'est que c'est une
excellente nouvelle
c'est même une brillante nouvelle je
vais essayer de vous expliquer pourquoi
j'ai besoin de quelques petites schéma
imaginé un groupe de 1000 personnes par
définition la prévalence d'une personne
malade sur 1000 c'est le tout petit
point rouge qui est là une personne est
malade clairement voilà tous les autres
sont en bonne santé
statistiquement maintenant si vous
testez toutes ces personnes 1000
personnes
vous avez un pour cent taux d'erreur ça
veut dire que vous aurez 10 personnes
qui seront déclarées malades alors
qu'elles ne sont pas c'est des faux
positifs
vous avez eu au total onze personnes
malades déclarés sur ce groupe 2000 ce
qui signifie que si vous avez un retour
positif de ce test
en réalité vous n'avez qu'une chance sur
onze d'être malade
c'est à dire 9% en d'autres termes vous
avez 91 % de chance d'être en bonne
santé malgré le retour du test positif
et c'est un renversement complet et vous
pouvez y mamou et me dire oui bon c'est
assez théorique ce truc là lâche un peu
mathématiques etc
pas du tout j'ai pris des chiffres
légèrement différent au fond de la
problématique du cancer du sein de la
conclusion est exactement la même et
justement ça fait l'objet de pas mal de
publications notamment aux états unis
naturellement on parle de dépistage
global avec ça mais ça concerne encore
d'autres d'autre chose ça peut concerner
dans la justice par exemple les
témoignages en fait de personnes qui
viennent devant un tribunal
cela peut concerner l'application ou la
détermination pour le
l'adn enfin de partir du moment où il
faut ne se passait sur l'adn pour
prouver la culpabilité de quelqu'un si
on se rattache à une base une base de
données adn global ça c'est celle des
éléments qui sont qui sont une réalité
et c'est précisément la raison
mathématiques pour laquelle la
surveillance de masse de vos emails de
vos sms de vos conversations
téléphoniques par la recherche de mots
clés et simplement une impossibilité
nombre de faux positifs et tellement
plus important que la probabilité de
tomber sur une discussion qu'ils font et
une discussion entre deux vrais
terroristes
voilà encore une dernière petite
expérience est assez amusante
on a repris des juges vous voyez je les
aime bien la citent le cas le cadre est
le suivant ses huit juges qui ont été
suivis 1112 carpes ont été traités
chacun de ces juges avaient en moyenne
22 ans d'expérience c'est qui est quand
même assez important c'est 1112 cas qui
ont été traitées représentaient 40% des
cas sur une durée de 10 mois
voilà le but où le travail des juges
c'est d'accorder ou non la liberté
conditionnelle sur l'étude d'un dossier
et d'une audition ils ont plusieurs
auditions par jour la journée se divise
en trois parties
à peu près deux heures 12h30 la première
partie ensuite ils font une pause la
même chose pose la même chose après il
termine la journée
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe en début de
journée les premiers cas traités en
moyenne 65% des libertés conditionnelles
sont accordés après deux heures et demie
de travail
le taux baisse
l'imagination peu fatigué li baisse à
combien base à 0
0% plus aucune liberté conditionnelle
n'était octroyé à la fin de cette
période et les juges ne se rendait pas
compte de cet effet ces salles de salles
pire mais c'est la réalité
ensuite ils vont se restaurer et il se
remettre au travail
vous avez le même schéma la troisième
période j'ai pas besoin de vous faire un
dessin ça descend encore plus vite mais
c'est exactement le même principe
voilà j'espère avoir simplement un petit
peu ouvert une porte de curiosité sur ce
que sont ces dissonances cognitives
ça fait partie ça fait partie de la vie
on est tous concernés
je crois que ça c'est ça c'est important
la la bonne nouvelle
au fond c'est que on peut dans une
certaine mesure maîtriser ses effets
mais la première démarche toute première
démarche c'est d'en prendre conscience
merci